the last time we see sam and bucky is
after steve leaves the shield with sam
sam is coming to terms with what it's
going to be to pick up that shield and
that's where we kick off the show the
legacy of that shield is complicated
when disney plus was announced there was
an opportunity to interweave the
cinematic universe with a television
university
the world of the falcon winter soldier
in the films is so big and you want this
show to feel as big and as engrossing i
think fans will definitely get a kick
out of seeing the continuation of that
kind of filmmaking that those movies had
sam
this has to be subtle
got it
the action side is so embedded in what
the mcu is but through the show we
wanted to look at the human side of the
characters
for bucky it's the legacy of the winter
soldier his anchor point to the person
who knew him before he was a murder
machine
no longer exists so bucky feels unmoored
in the series and is looking for his
purpose and sam wilson is very much
doing the same thing when steve first
told me about the shield the first words
i said were feels like it's someone
else's i felt like we would be dishonest
just on a human level if we had this
black man just accept the symbol without
having real ambivalence about it with
this series we've been able to give a
level of sincerity and humanity to him
you get a real sense of what this
character sam wilson really is the
notion of what blackness means in
america ties very much into sam's
journey through the events of the show
there's a fight out there and then
there's our fight here and bro you have
taken them both on
let's get to work
the scope of these six episodes is
really amazing i mean it's a huge story
falcon and winter soldiers aren't really
vibrant and electric characters so when
you are thrust into the action you sink
into the narrative and where the story
ultimately goes
you